[Música]
es hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo a América por ello me acompaña
en el estudio mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge bienvenido no podemos empezar con
otro tema arrancó en Suiza la reunión
anual del foro económico mundial con la
advertencia de que este año es probable
que se produzca una recesión mundial Y
es que una reciente encuesta de Price
waterhouse Cooper revela que el 73% de
los líderes empresariales del mundo
predicen que el crecimiento mundial
disminuiría en los próximos 12 meses
entonces cada cinco se mostraron
preocupados de que sus empresas no duren
más de una década otra encuesta
publicada por el foro reveló que dos
tercios esperan una recesión mundial
este año esta semana más de 2,700
ejecutivos banqueros y economistas se
reencuentran en davos por primera vez
desde enero del 2020 Allí se encuentra
nuestra periodista especializada en
economía Daniela Blandón y nos brinda
más detalles del inicio de este
importante encuentro
comienza oficialmente este foro
económico mundial en Suiza y el informe
que se ha llevado a todas las miradas el
día de hoy es el que entrega oxfam
internacional está ong sin ánimo de
lucro que hace énfasis en la desigualdad
y que entrega su informe anualmente en
el marco de este evento para este año
los entre los hallazgos está que el 1%
de la población se quedó con la mitad de
la riqueza generada entre 2020 y 2022 es
decir después de la pandemia y el 99%
restante de la población se quedó con el
otro 50% de esos 42 billones de dólares
en fortuna que se han generado por eso
hace
énfasis en Solicitar a los diferentes
gobiernos que trabajen en imponer
nuevos exámenes a las personas con más
altos recursos específicamente hablan de
un 5% de gravamen para los
multimillonarios y dicen que con esto al
menos dos mil personas dos mil millones
de personas podrían salir de la pobreza
en los próximos años también ha pedido
gobiernos que no se sigan concentrando
en Elevar los impuestos como el impuesto
al valor agregado o IVA sino que se
concentre en las personas más
privilegiadas
Jorge Hablamos ahora de otra reunión
importante y es la que se realiza en
Bruselas la de los ministros de economía
y finanzas de la eurozona Y es que
durante la primera reunión del año que
realizan aseguran estar confiados en
evitar una recesión en 2023 gracias a
los buenos resultados económicos de
finales del año pasado los socios
reconocen que los precios y la energía y
la inflación constituyen un desafío y
Por tanto se entrarán todas sus medidas
políticas en bajar la inflación Y hacer
que la ralentización del crecimiento no
sea tan drástico se espera que la
inflación entre los 20 países que
comparten la moneda se ralentice hasta
situarse entre el 6% anual y el 7% de
este año frente al 8 o 9% que registró
en el año 2022 esto según pachaldo enoje
él es el del euro grupo se refirió a la
reciente ley de reducción de la
inflación de Estados Unidos se dijo que
podría tener consecuencias la comisión
europea que es el brazo ejecutivo de
este bloque está revisando la
legislación estadounidense por
considerar que afecta sectores como el
Automotriz en Europa y brindará también
pronto sus conclusiones a los ministros
de economía Jorge la ex primer ministra
británica listros tuvo un paso bastante
efímero por down Street si lo podemos
decir así Ahora el banco de Inglaterra
dice que la crisis financiera que
desataron sus políticas ya pasó también
efímera efímero y atropellado de cierta
forma esto según el gobernador del banco
de Inglaterra Andrew bayle quien
compareció ante el comité de tesorería
de la cámara de los comunes según él los
efectos financieros que dejaron estas
polémicas medidas Fiscales de la ex
primera ministralice fueron ya superados
en septiembre pasado como recordaremos
pros anunció un agresivo recorte de
impuestos sin financiación que disparó
el costo británica llevó a varios fondos
de pensiones al borde del colapso y
obligó al banco de Inglaterra a
intervenir con la compra de emergencia
de bonos públicos el gobierno el
gobernador del banco aseguró que se
deshicieron de todos los bonos
adquiridos en ese programa de emergencia
y que los beneficios ya fueron
incorporados a las cuentas trimestrales
de la entidad Jorge en América Latina
tenemos que ir a Venezuela porque ya
están tomando Más Fuerzas más fuerza
estas protestas anti gubernamentales en
las que están pidiendo mejoras
salariales Así es protestan maestros
enfermeros jubilados y también otros
trabajadores que se manifestaron en
Caracas para exigir este aumento
salarial que compense la rápida
depreciación de la moneda local datos
del observatorio venezolano de
conflictividad social registraron 50
protestas solamente este lunes y más de
150 en todo el país en la última semana
el salario promedio mensual de los
maestros en Venezuela es de unos 500
bolívares o sea unos 25 dólares y según
ellos apenas alcanza para pagar los
gastos del transporte público escuchamos
hoy los educadores ahí están aquí
protestando para que comience la
discusión del contrato colectivo y que
tengamos seguridad porque no es posible
que diera un Bono tratando de suspender
esta manifestación de 580 bolívares
nosotros no queremos bonos queremos es
que nos ponga un sueldo que nos alcance
suficientemente como lo establece la el
artículo 91 de la Constitución pues
Jorge justamente a usted le agradecemos
por esta información económica y vamos a
continuar en directo Ah porque
justamente nos vamos a Caracas para
ampliar esta información hasta la
próxima
[Música]